you know sometimes you have a bad
experience with a company or something
personal that happens to you whether
it's
you know
testing with a drug you take a drug and
next thing you know
your family member gets addicted to
vicodin they can't get off of vicodin
and they harm themselves so for the rest
of your life all you're doing is
studying
vicodin right and doing whatever you can
because you're just like obsessed to get
to the bottom of it to see what really
happens sometimes
in military and accidental somebody dies
or there's a suicide and
all these other things that happen you
commit your life to wanting to know more
about it did this kind of get you to say
you know what i want to kind of get to
the bottom to see what the hell is going
on over here kind of like i don't want
to have anything to do with this i'm
moving on to my life
uh so i just want to say that
there's no sort of revenge scheme i have
against facebook i'm just one little
person i'm not here that
like if i was trying to go after
facebook i would definitely have tried
to go on like
oprah or many other different shows and
try to like say my story
for one i don't really want to be famous
known as hey you're the guy that watched
uh fetuses be smashed with hammers for
10 hours every day six days a week like
that's not really what i want to be
known for
um the reason that i'm doing this
and i speak out is because
when i
started working with facebook
i thought that the least i could do
is try to help the people and animals
whose last moments were being desecrated
even if it's on video or picture
people that were mocking it making fun
of it getting off to it with sexual
pleasure
i wanted to at least
help these animals and people and their
dying moments
and at least give them closure
that's all i wanted to do is try to help
and they even kind of sold it to us when
we first started with training is that
you're going to be the police of
facebook
you're going to be policing it
monitoring it you're going to make it a
safer place
and i really bought into that
i
it's i want to
i wish i could you know wash my hands of
it all and just go
i don't care anymore i don't want to
hear it anymore
but there was
there was too much
that happened on facebook that
should not have ever been allowed
and i would probably put money on it
those same people are still making that
same content
one thing that really got to me
and this happened um
last year
and it was this woman that works uh that
was an activist
and she was telling me that she was
going
to congress to talk about these specific
things
so we talked a couple times and last
year she called me
and she said did you work
on these specific types of things in
texas and it was about these girls that
were being
held
in their parents basement and being used
as like sex toys and prostitutes
i said yes i did work on that
apparently
the
authorities just found out at that time
and arrested them
that was two years after i left facebook
and i wrote the report on that
and i
did my best to make sure the authorities
would try to get it make sure facebook
would take it seriously but facebook
wouldn't let it get out
and so those girls suffered for two
extra years
and
there were many other cases similar to
that
and they wanted me to confirm that
it was that i actually sent a report in
and discuss that stuff
and
just makes me mad that they suffered two
extra years because facebook couldn't
even
do the right thing and let the
authorities know what it was
there was
another instance and it was one of the
first things i saw
and it was these two boys
and they grabbed an iguana by the tail
and they smashed the iguana onto the
pavement
and the iguana was just
screaming i've never heard an iguana
scream and i don't think most people
have
and they kept doing it and doing it and
smashing the iguana onto the pavement
until just a bloody
pulp with a tail
and apparently those boys had their own
private facebook page
where they were bashing other animals to
death as well
and they never took it down that iguana
video was still up
and they were making more videos
of more animals they were killing
and they were getting paid for it
that's why i want to get this message
out is because
people are suffering
and nobody's doing anything about it
and you may think that it's all just on
a different screen
it's not real
they want you to sensitize to it
but people are actually making money off
this thing and i think that's the most
disgusting thing in the world
is that people are getting paid and
there are people that want to pay you
to make this content
and that's why i do this and yes i would
like to get the bottom of this i would
like to know more about
what the heck they're doing in there
for somebody
you know
for somebody who's on the inside
uh sean
who this is your world
what what can facebook do meaning
is it in their control to be able to
address this and stop it that's one so
let's just say the answer is yes if the
answer is yes
what can they do they've been talking
about ai for a long time
uh
you know from your perspective and and
again sean i appreciate you for sharing
that
and it's 100 felt from speaking to you
it's very obvious that
uh you're not doing this for a dollar
you're doing this because you know
animals and people matter to you even
when you said earlier i'm not a politics
guy i don't follow politics i don't know
what's going on with politics but it's
not my world but what would you say
what would you say
you know on what they can do to
eliminate all of this is it ai is it
internal team is it
what do you think that is
so
the the first thing that they truly need
to do is if facebook really wants to
make this change is zuckerberg has to
step down because zuckerberg is kind of
he's the one in the way of all this he's
the one that makes all decisions
he's the one that signs off on
everything and
this is zuckerberg's creation
so
if we had someone that was not him in
control then perhaps we could actually
get something done because i ha i don't
see zuckerberg ever
bending the the knees so to speak to
actually make these changes
what i think needs to be changed could
be
facebook needs to be divided up into
different segments
and then have these different
independent individuals actually in
charge of these segments
maybe we really do need some sort of
government influence
uh looking into this i know a lot of
people will claim that that would be
like an oversight of the american
government
but when something has grown this big
and it has such an
importance in not just our society but
world society maybe it needs to not be a
private company and maybe it should be
some sort of public entity
i mean facebook
is so big along with other social media
sites that
maybe we shouldn't consider it a private
company maybe we should consider it as
something as a public square maybe it
should be considered something that
would be the equivalent of going out in
public and saying something and not
something that is controlled by a
private entity
um the only other thing i could possibly
think of facebook to do is maybe
facebook just needs to do a total revamp
of their policies
because when i was working there even
though the policies were changing by the
day they were only changing by specific
current events and they would only
change for like specific people
so like a great example would be um
during the justice kavanaugh hearings
i'll use that example again um
normally you're not allowed to make any
sort of disparaging bullying comments
about people that claim that they are
survivors of rape or molestation or
anything like that
but facebook made an exception with dr
ford so you were actually allowed to
make fun of her for that
oh i i apologize
okay um
and they made an exception you were
saying they made an exception for dr
ford yes so so everybody could make fun
of her everybody could like claim that
she was asking for it she was a [ __ ] she
was a [ __ ] they could claim that
and for normal cases you're not because
it would get deleted
um but those were like the examples of
like policies changing for specific
people or specific events
and their policies were so hyper
specific i think
in a normal ruling body we could all
agree that
you know
killing killing animals online should be
banned i don't think there's any reason
why we should have it on there
but apparently there's still like a lot
of stipulations like you can kill
animals on video
as long as it's in like an eating
preparing food setting
or you can also kill animals if it's in
a perceived self-defense setting where
there's a lot of people that took
advantage of those and they just like
mutilated a bear because they claimed
that they were hunting a bear in
self-defense
and so they had a caption that said like
killing that said like you know we're
killing the bear in self-defense and
they were like ripping its jaw off and
like just torturing the thing while it
was still alive and drugged up and
facebook allowed that because the
caption said oh it was in self-defense
so of course we can allow that
so it's just like these policies are
just
they're so easy to find loopholes on so
if you like this sort of shortcut from
an interview i did click over here to
watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]